my name is alaska and i am here at this
time
to read buzzfeed's thirst tweet
okay can we just take a minute to
appreciate how gorgeous alaska is in
drag and how hot he is out of drag best
of both worlds sis
i feel like hannah montana that's nice
that's polite i appreciate you whatever
your name is alaska thunder is so hot
sorry not sorry no punctuation no
periods no capital letters no cap i
don't think you have to be sorry about
that i accept this in the words of
tatiana thank you alaska morgan
fairchild thunder 5000 esquire is the
most beautiful sexy alien i've ever laid
eyes on that's all it's wild that this
person knows my full government name
alaska morgan fairchild thunder 5000
esquire because i'm a lawyer the fact
alaska thunder can make a mono brow look
sexy i'm so done this person is
exasperated
they are over it they can't take any
more and you know what i love a monobrow
i know exactly what they're referring to
but this is my hair music video and i
insisted on having a brow that went all
the way across the goddesses and the
muses spoke to me and said that's what
you're doing and i loved that look i
felt really pretty and sasha velour has
gone on to make a mono brow like really
gorgeous and really a thing so thank you
i would let alaska thunder roll me up
and smoke me any day of the week i don't
know what that means it is a compliment
though thursdays and tuesdays work best
for me
omfg
i hated alaska thunder so much when i
first heard her talk
but now
i'm just a whole man
i-l-y
white queen there's a lot
this is like a maya angelou poem because
in just a few simple words
this artist has taken us around the
world
made us feel so many things i feel
insulted
exalted insulted again and confused it
started as so many love affairs do it
started with hatred they wish i was dead
because of the way i spoke but now how
things have changed i'm just a whole man
that's respectful ma'am and then white
queen
is that a thing that kids say now is it
like a greeting let's move on does
anyone else find alaska extremely hot in
drag like extremely hot like 100 out of
10 would bang like the hottest drag
queen you know i think there are so many
like hot sexy beautiful drag queens out
there i don't know that i'm the hottest
one but twitter is a place for hyperbole
people say oh my god i'm falling on the
floor i'm screaming
when they're really just staring at
their phone at alaska 5000 oh they're
they're adding me so it's direct this is
basically like calling my landline boy
laska you look like a sexy gay porn
version of spock if you weren't sharon's
i'd be gagging for a mind meld which i'm
sure there actually is a gayborne
version of spock they must have done it
and i'm also not sharon but we are
friends i want alaska thunder to give me
a tracheotomy with her heels
tracheotomy is when you can't breathe
and you have to stab a hole in the neck
in order to like put a tube in so you
can breathe properly i'm not going to
perform this procedure with my nails
shoes are filthy i want sasha velour and
alaska thunder to pull off my legs
okay i don't what does that even me are
you are you a spider alaska thunder 5000
will have you pondering if you should
practice
moaning in the mirror because she's
sounds hot
one of my hugest turns off
turns off is
horrible
grammar were they using voice to text
dictation it's a turn off and for that
reason it's a no for me at alaska 5000 i
want you to paint my face then sit on it
kiss the face you're my drag inspiration
it would ruin the makeup i have no
judgment about like queens who
do it in drag
it's a very common thing i never have
just because there's like too much
things glued to me i'm not going to
paint your face and then sit on it in
that order at alaska 5000
lick my hashtag anus
that's graphic i wouldn't share this
with my mom i get it that they're
referencing the name of my first album
which was anus if you bring me the vinyl
of anus i will lick it in a meet and
greet if we like sanitize it first and
that's a promise
snake heart [ __ ] me with your rattle and
fangs oh queen of snakes heart snake
beautiful and the use of emojis as a
framing device thought went into this i
mean with your rattle and fangs it's
almost poetic it's almost i am vic
pentameter it's shakespearean i would go
out on a date with this person and this
is the last buzzfeed thirst tweet at
alaska 5000 i [ __ ] love you i'd
totally let you buffalo bill me and use
my skin for a sickening unique look
hashtag meatsuit glamour
this is
ah
buffalo i thought it was talking about
buffalo bill like my character from
buffalo bills barnyard bodies on drag
race which was a nice like farmer but
this is like they want me to keep them
in a well
spray them with a hose if they don't put
lotion on themselves
and then skin them alive and then use
their skin for a sickening unique look
it would be a sickening unique look it
doesn't seem like something that i would
do but
i do like that they spelled glamour with
you so thank you for that thank you so
much buzzfeed i encourage you to listen
to my new song red
and all the new forthcoming music from
my next album red for
phil and we're gonna be going on tour
with the music next year so check it out
and i wrote a book oh my god it's called
my name's yours
and you can pre-order it now
you